Maureen is with us in New York City to
start off this hour a marine how are you
how are you
just as I'm how can I help I'm 23 years
old as you said I'm living in New York
City with a full-time job I've never had
a credit card and I don't want one
doesn't sit well with me but lately a
lot of my co-workers and friends are
telling me that I have to get one to
build credit I've only had 150 hundred
dollar student loan they paid off within
six months of graduating I have a
month-to-month living situation so I'm
not under a lease and I've never had one
but I'm looking into moving into an
apartment next year I'd be signing my
first lease so I'm afraid that I'll get
denied an apartment because of my lack
of credit but I want to know is no
credit significantly worse an average
credit and if so is there a way for me
to build credit otherwise okay well the
only way to build your credit score or
to build credit is to borrow money
why so then you can pay it back why so
that you have the opportunity to borrow
more money and raise your score why so
you can borrow more money why so that
you can have the opportunity to raise
your score and borrow more money this is
this is a dog chasing its tail that
keeps bankers rich mm-hmm the only
reason you build credits why so you can
go credit why so you can build credit
like she can go credit it's all about
going into debt the whole thing is and
staying in debt which you have just said
that you're broke friends don't think is
a good idea well it broke people right
in front of your financial plan that's
generally a good thing so the reality is
is that the downside of living with a
high credit score if you have an 800
credit score it basically means you paid
roughly $100,000 an interest over the
last few years so because it's an I love
debt score it's the only way to build a
credit score is to go into debt it's the
only possible way there's not another
way to do it and so worshipping at the
altar of the great FICO as your provider
in life is a really bad altar to worship
at it'll get it'll to keep you in debt
the rest of your life so if you want to
play that side of it
you can play that side of it there's not
a really good middle ground as the
problem you've either got to sell out
yeah either got to sell out to FICO or
you got to sell out to I'm gonna avoid
FICO because the middle ground means you
have a low credit score which means you
paid a bunch of interest and still
didn't get the benefits having a FICO
score so now what does that mean in
reality I do not have a FICO score okay
okay I'm a multi-millionaire so what
that means is I can go down to the local
apartment complex that requires a FICO
score to rent an apartment if that one
does not all of them do and I walk in
and a 26 year old property manager says
no mr. multi-millionaire we cannot rent
you an apartment now I can write a check
and buy the complex but I can't rent an
apartment there that's how dumb but
asinine this whole idea is and so what
it amounts to is this can you find an
apartment in New York City that does not
require a FICO score yes will you get
turned down for some that require a FICO
score yes and I would face exactly the
same obstacles that you are facing so
you're either going to have to find
people who will work with you and do
business with you without a FICO score
over the scope of your life or you need
to go worship at the altar of the great
FICO there's not a good middle ground
and so you're gonna have the challenge
of being in debt the rest of your life
or you're gonna have the challenge of
occasionally someone because you don't
have a FICO score will not let you do
something and believe me I personally
have experienced that type of FICO score
ISM it's a type of it's it's an ism it's
like sexism and racism and you know it's
prejudice is what it is and so I've been
turned down for things my my auto
insurance is higher because I don't have
a FICO score it's it's just illegal but
they just do it I mean it's just wrong
but they just do it and so you know that
you're gonna run into stuff like that
and you just have to decide which game
I'm going to play overall because
there's not a really good middle ground
you see what I'm saying if you sorta
build your credit and I'm sorta in debt
you
sword I have a FICO score and your cycle
score will suck and then that's why
that's worse than not having one I think
you could go into an apartment manager
who has a brain not all of them do and
say look hey I'm 22 I have no I don't
have any debt you know what that means I
got a lot of money I can pay the rent
that's what it means if somebody comes
to me I own a bunch of rental property
if somebody comes to us and says I have
no FICO score that means you have no
debt that means you have the money to
pay the rent I like you as a tenant but
I have a brain and not everyone has a
brain that rents apartments and so
you're going to run into people that
aren't allowed to or choose not to think
in our culture because the FICO score
has become so ubiquitous and it's out of
control so that that's what your thing
is and you know you have to get a credit
card no that's just people trying
justify their stupidity you don't have
to but you can make a choice too you can
decide to go that way and go into debt
so that you can go into debt so that you
can go into debt so that you can go into
debt and be a dog chasing its tail for
the rest of your life